[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم وهذه اخبار المساء
بدايه بالعناوين
تطالب من بكين تدخل للضغط على موسكو
[موسيقى]
وزير التعليم الحكومه
الافغانيه امام الفتيات
ويحرمهن من حق استكمال التعليم
[موسيقى]
الاراضي العراق
لاستعاده دوره
واشنط تقول لنا ايران فوتت فرصه احياء
الاتفاقناوي وحطمت كل الامل بالعوده اليه
الون ماسك يخوضوا رحله البحث عن رئيس
تنفيذي جديد لتويتر خلف له
[موسيقى]
وقبل البدايه بالاخبار السياسيه ومشاكل
العالم هذه صور من الرباط الاحتفال
واستقبال الجماهير المغربيه
جدا في وجهه كبار همم
حتى يعني في المباريات التي خسرها همم كان
اللاعب مميزا جدا ويعني لعب ببساله كما
يقال في الملاعب
الجماهير المغاربيه قررت استقبال المنتخب
المغربي استقبال الابطال وكان فعلا هذا ما
يستحقه
الاحتفالات
[موسيقى]
العربيه
كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
ومشاهد الاحتفال في المغرب مشاهد الاحتفال
في بوليس ايرس المنتخب الارجنتيني وصل الى
صحا الاساسيه في بوليس ايرس ساحه العامه
ويعني حضر علمتني حافله مكشوفه
لي تحيه الجماهير والمحبين الكره القدم
وطبعا كان ميسي يحتضن كاس العالم العالم
اذا كان الكاس الحقيقي ام شبيه له يعني
ثلاثيا لاي طريقه او ما الى ذلك ولكن
راينا كاس العالم في حضن ميسي وكانت همم
كان هو فريقه همم يخترقون الحشود ويحيون
الجماهير
الى السياسه غدا الاربعاء يحدد رئيس روسيف
لازم اهدافه جيش بلاده للعام 2023 اهداف
ستحدد خلالها اجتماع مع كبار او سيحدد
خلاله في اجتماع مع كبار القاده العسكريين
وفقا لما اعلن عنه الكريم بينما تدخل او
تدخل الحرب على اوكرانيا شهرها التاسع
وبالتزامن مع هذا الاعلان حذر مسؤولون
عسكريون غربيون من احتمال عوده التصعيد في
الهجمات الروسيه على اوكرانيا غير
مستبعدين احتمال شاني هجوم من شمال
اوكرانيا تحديدا من الاراضي البلعروسيه
حليفه بوتن الاولى في هذه الحرب تطورات
دفعت بالمانيا الى تجديد طلبها من الصين
للضغط على روسيا لانهاء الحرف اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
زهره رئيس الاوكراني
المنطقه الاكثر سخونه في الهجمات بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه كما قلد
الرئيس خلال زيارته عدد من الجنود
بالاوسمه ووصف نائب رئيس الاوكراني
الاكثر شجاعه
من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا تومي كاتيا
لماذا يحتاج بوتين لخطه عسكريه جديده فيما
الحرب في شهرها التاسع هل يشعر بان الخطه
الحاليه فشلت
مرحبا بك ريما بالفعل الرئيس الروسي الذي
مرتين سيعقد اجتماعا يوم ان يوم غد موسعه
مع اعضاء وزاره الدفاع الروسيه جميع
القيادات
وبالاخص طبعا وزير الدفاع الروسيه التي
سيقوم بتقديم همم
تقرير كامل عن العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وجميع الاسلحه التي وصلت الى
يد القوات الروسيه هناك وعلى هذا الاساس
سيتم طبعا اتخاذ قرارات جديده وضع خط جديد
همم للتقدم في هذه العمليه العسكريه همم
روسيا طبعا هذا الاجتماع هو بعد زياره
الرئيس الروسي يفضل
يوم امس الى بيلاروسيا ايضا كانت بحضور
وزير الدفاع الروسي ووزير الخارجيه الروسي
همم طبعا ياتي هذا الاجتماع على اساس ما
تم التواصل اليه يوم امس من قرا مشتركه مع
بيلاروسيا سريعا هل نتحدث عن خطه عسكريه
جديده فقط ام ميزانيه دفاعيه جديده ايضا
لانه السلاح يحتاج للفلوس يعني
حقيقه ريما لم يتم الكشف حتى الان عن
تفاصيل هذا الاجتماع سواء سيكون فقط
الحديث عن خطط او توسيع الميزانيه
العسكريه لدعم القوات الروسيه همم في جميع
الجبهات وبالاخص بعد همم اولا في فصل
الشتاء القاسيه وبالاخص طبعا الجبهات التي
تقف عندها القوات الروسيه بعد الانسحاب
الذي شاهدناه في خرسون وفي علم مواجهات
القاسيه التي نشهدها الان في دومباس هناك
طبعا قصف شديد من الجانب الاوكراني تتعرض
اليه هذه الاراضي اذا حتى الان لم يتم
الكشف عن التفاصيل انتظر يوم غد نرى ما هي
الاتفاقات او هي ال- همم القرارات التي
ستظهر عن رئيس
العمل للمزيدنا للمساجدات من موسكو كانت
معنا مراسله العربيه
تواصل القوات الروسيه البحث عن العديد من
الاستراتيجيات وتكتيكيات الحربيه التي
يمكن ان تساعدها في قلبي معادله الحرب
لصالحها فمع تصاعدي حده التوتر حوله هجوم
الروسي الجديد تقوم مرتزقه فاجنر في مدينه
باخموت من الناحيه الجنوبيه بتنفيذ العديد
من الهجمات على الجيش الاوكراني بحيث نفذت
هجوما في بخموط وهجوم اخر على محور اليمن
وهنا سيسمح بالاستيلاء او سيسمح لاستيلاء
على مارينكا للقوات الروسيه بتجاوز بلدار
الى الجنوب الغربي والتقدم الى الشمال
هو خوفوا او كره خوفه وهي مركز نقل
اوكراني رئيسي
كما افادت مصادر عسكريه في دونيتسك بان
القوات المواليه لروسيا توسيطر على مدينه
مريكا شمال غرب المقاطعه وتدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للانسحاب كما يوصل الجيش
الروسي القصف في مدينه
افديفكا شمال غرب مقاطعه دوناتس ويحاولوا
الدخول من اطراف المدينه اما في بلدتي
كلاشافيكا
جنوب مدينه باخمود والتي تشهد معارك ضاريه
بين الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني فعلى الرغم
من سيطره القوات الروسيه على المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه والجنوبيه للبلده
والسيطره ايضا على كاملي خطوط الامداد بما
فيها سكك الحديد الا ان الجيش الاوكراني
لم ينسحب حتى الان من كلاش اوف
ويتحسن في بلده ايفانوسكي المتخمه
وحسب تقارير امنيه فان روسيا تواصل توسيع
نفوذها من شبه الجزيره من شبه جزيره القرم
الى ضواحي روستوف جنوبا فيما تحصن
اوكرانيا ترسانتها العسكريه باسلحه
اوروبيه وامريكيه لاخراج القوات الروسيه
من اراضيها خبراء عسكريون واميون قالوا ان
وقفه حرب اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل ابرزها
تشديد الاوكرانيين على خروج روسيا من
اراضيها كما دخلتها اول مره وانسحاب
الجنود الروس من اقليم بس بالكامل
[موسيقى]
تاكيدا لما نشرته العربيه امر وزير
التعليم العالي في حكومه طالبان
بافغانستان باغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات
وحمل القرار الذي حصلت العربيه على نسخه
منه توقيع وزير التعليم العالي ندى محمد
نديم وامرت الوزاره بحسب القرار جميع
الجامعات الحكوميه والخاصه بوقف تعليم
الطالبات حتى اشعار اخر جاء ذلك بعد سلسله
قرارات مماثله حيث تم منع الفتيات في
افغانستان من دخول المتنزهات
وصلات الرياضه والملاحق
من كابو المراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
عبد الله هل تحدث مع الفتيات
احدهم ال يعني احدى الفتيات التي في
الجامعه مثلا كيف هو طموح ما هو ردود
الفعل في الشارع
وبالتالي لم نتحدث الى اي فتيات
اليهن غدا باذن الله نعم بامر قاطعا في
فرمان جديد اوقفت وزاره التعليم العاليه
الافغانيه تعليم الفتيات في الجامعات بدء
من يوم غد الاربعاء وذكر قرار وزاره بان
الامر يشمل جميع الجامعات الحكوميه الخاصه
في جميع انحاء البلاد وجاء في البيان بناء
على قرار مجلس الوزراء نبلغكم جميعا
بتنفيذ الامر وهو تعليق وتعليم الفتيات
حتى الاشعار الثاني وبالتالي ستكون
الجامعات مغلقه امام الفتيات حتى الاشعار
الثاني ولم يحدد قرار الوزاره التوقيت
لاعاده فتح الجامعات امام الفتيات ثانيه
للفتيات او تدرس هذا القرار يعني هل هذا
وارد هل من سيوقف هذه الحكومه عن هذه
القرارات
ربما ربما واذا ما اغلقت طالبان المدارس
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي والمدارس
الثانويه والاعداديه فمن المحتمل ان تغلق
كذلك المدارس الابتدائيه وطالبان تبرر
فرامينا وقراراتها بحسب ما بحسب حوارنا مع
بعض منهم بان هات تسعى لتوفير حقوق المراه
وفقا شريعه الاسلاميه وتنشغل بالبث في
المناهج التعليميه والذي الرسميه للفتيات
وبسبب المشاكل الاقتصاديه والامنيه
والظروف غير المواتيه لتعليم الفتيات
اغلقوا المدارس ومن ثم الجامعات امام
البنات وبعد التغلب على هذه المشاكل سيتم
اعاده فتحها امامهن هذه كلها تبريرات
طالبا ولكن الاوساط الافغانيه ليست مقتنعه
بهذه التبريدات لان طالبان على سده الحكم
منذ اكثر
يجي هل من جهه دوليه عالميه او عربيه ممكن
ان تؤثر على حكومه طالبان من بهذا العصر
لا يعطي التعليم للفتيات
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي مغلقه امام
الفتيات الافغانيات لنحو 17 شهرا وقد تسبب
اغلاق المدارس الثانويه بردود فعل وطنيه
والدوليه بما فيها ردود دول اسلاميه في
افغانستان احتجت النساء في مدن مختلفه لكن
لم تخثر اي من هذه الجهود عن نتائج حتى
الان
وفي امريكا وبريطانيا
بمنع الفتيات في افغانستان من التعليم
الجامعات شكرا لعبد الله نادر مراسل
العربيه
[موسيقى]
والى الاردن هو مؤتمر بغداد بدورته
الثانيه والذي اختتمت اعمله قبل نحو ثلاث
ساعات البيان الختامي للمؤتمر شدد على
الوقوف الى جانب العراق
ومساندته لاستعاده دوره المحوري في
المنطقه كما ركز المجتمعون على دعم جهود
العراق لتحقيق التكامل الاقتصادي والتعاون
في قطاعات عده اضافه لدعم بغداد في مكافحه
الارهاب وتعزيز امن البلاد واستقراره
بينما عبر وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان عن ترحيب المملكه باستعاده
بغداد دورها الاقليمي والدولي ورفض اي
اعتداء على اي شبر من ارض العراق
المملكه وقوفها جنب الى جنب مع العراق
وترجمتها
تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
ورخاء جيرانها والمنطقه يا جماعه
في ما اكد رئيس مجلس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني خلال كلمه القاها في
المؤتمر اكد مجددا على سعي العراق لبناء
علاقات جيده مع دول المنطقه والعالم مشددا
على ان بلاده لن تسمح باستخدام اراضيها
منطلقا لاي اعتداء على دوله اخرى
تعاون وثيقه ومتوازنه مع كل الشركاء
الاقليميين والدوليين
وينها بنفسه عن اصطفافات المحاور واجواء
التصعيد وينشدو سياسه التهدئه وخفض
التوترات وفي ذات الوقت يرفض التدخل بشؤون
الداخليه
ومس سيادته او الاعتداء على اراضيه
ولا يمكن اعتماد ومبدا القوه في في مساعي
حل الخلاف او الاختلاف ولا نسمح باستخدام
هذا المبدا ضد العراق بنفس الوقت لا نقبل
ان ينطلق اي وتهديد من العراق ضد اي دوله
من دول الجوار او المنطقه
هكذا تطمينات من هكذا مسؤول رفيع في
العراق هل هذا يعني ان الميليشيات
العراقيه ستلتزم او ايران مثلا بعدم اطلاق
اي اعتداء على دول
مجاوره للعراق
مساء الخير سترينا لكي وليساعد مشاهدي
قناه العربيه الافاضل هذا المؤتمر هو
الثاني سبق للعراق ان اضاع فرصه كبيره في
المؤتمر الاول الذي عقد في بغداد ولم
يستطع رئيس الوزراء الكاظمي انا ذاك ان
يجير هذا الدعم الاقليمي على شكل مصالح
ممكن ان تفكك جزء من ازمات العراق
الاقليميه كما تعلمين ويعلم الساده
المشاهدون ان العراق لديه مشاكل امنيه
ومشاكل مائيه مع تركيا وايران ولديه مشاكل
حدوديه مع الكويت وهذا التجمع الاقليمي
والدولي يفترض بالرئيس السوداني ان يستفيد
منه الى اقصى المذايات خصوصا وان وضع
العراق المالي ممتاز والبلد يشهد حاله من
الاستقرار هنالك معرق الوحيد امام الرئيس
السوداني همم الرئيس السوداني هو وليد
حكومه ايطاليه قريبه من ايران
ولديها تمثيل نيابي كبير ربما تضغط عليه
كما ضغطت في السابق على الرئيس الكاظمي
واصبح المؤتمر الاول مؤتمر بيانات وشعارات
لم ااه نرى تطبيقات له على ارض الواقع نحن
نخشى ان يكون مؤتمر عمان الثاني شبيه
بالمؤتمر الاول
سانتقل الى كلمه رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون خلال كلمته في مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون
والشراكه جدد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل دعم
بلاده للعراق مناديدا بتاثيرات الخارجيه
التي يتعرض لها وداعيا في الوقت نفسه
الدول المشاركه في القمه الى المساعده في
تعزيز امن العراق والمنتخب
اغنيه
جديده
العراق اليوم
تؤثر على المنطقه ككل وبالتالي عقد هذا
المؤتمر بهذه التشكيله لكي تجتمع في قاعه
واحده كل الدول والامم التي يمكنها ان
تساهم في تعزيز السياده العراق وبالتالي
استقراره وامن المنطقه
الاولى في الاشهر الاخيره اقل له يجلس
المجتمع الدولي يعني كان الاوروبيين رئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون السعوديين كانوا الكثير
من الدول العربيه في هذا الاجتماع ببغداد
اثنين في الاردن هل هو ايضا لقاء غير
مباشر بين المجتمع الدولي وايران
بحثت ملفات غير العراق برايك
لا هذا المؤتمر الثاني المؤتمر انا كنت
حاضر المؤتمر الاول في بغداد ونفس
الشخصيات كانت حاضره رئيس ماكرون والعربيه
السعوديه واغلب الدول كانت حاضر انا اعتقد
ان دور العراق المحوري في المنطقه اصبح
يعني عامل شد ما بين المجتمع الاقليمي
باستثناء ايران وما بين ايران المجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي هذه الدول تحاول شد
العراق باتجاه محيطه الاقليمي والمجتمع
الدولي المنفتح همم على حساب ان يذهب
العراق بمقدراته الى جانب ايران وروسيا
هل هو اجتماع مع ايران ايضا تحت عنوان
العراق
لا هو في الاساس للعراق اولا برئيس حكومه
جديد
لديه طموح كبير في ان يحقق منجز ومن خلال
العراق يسمع وزير خارجيه ايران راي العراق
اولا وراي المجتمع الدولي ثانيا من المهم
يعني انا كان جدا ضروري حضور وزير خارجيه
ايران لكي يرى حجم الدعم وحجم الاسناد
الدولي للعراق وربما يدفع الايرانيين
لسياسه اكثر عقلانيه للتعامل مع الشان
العراقي في صورته الجديده
ونشره المساء مستمره ونتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
اما تم في 30 يونيو
لاول مره بشهادته علنا امام القضاء ويقر
بمسؤوليته عنقلاب عن 89
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس مجلس القياده
رئاسي اليماني رشاد محمد العليمي في لقاء
خاصه به قناه العربيه بان الاداره
الامريكيه ترد على الادله التي يتم
تقديمها والتي تثبت التورد طائرا باليمن
بانها غير كافيه
ان هناك دعم ايراني غير محدود لهذه
الجماعه
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
وكل ما كان ياتي في امريكا الى صنعاء كنا
نسلم
قال نحن مقتنعين في البنتاجون
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
رشاد العليمي اشار الى انه اختار المانيا
لزيارتها كاول دوله اجنبيه لانهم يدركون
تاثيرا الموقف الالماني على الحوثيين
الذين يراهنون عليهم حتى ان بعض عناصر
الحسي موجوده هناك
لدوله اجنبيه خارج اطار المنطقه العربيه
كان زياره لالمانيا
لانه ندرك ان الموقف الالماني موقف مهم
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والحوثيين كانوا يراهنوا كثيرا على على
على المواقف الالمانيه
وكان لهم تواجد عناصرهم همم
الناعمه اللي بنسميها اللي تتواجد في
اوروبا في امريكا
وحصل تغير في الموقع الاوروبي
من القاهره ينضم الينا الدكتور عبد الحفيظ
النهاري رئيس الدائره الاعلاميه في
المؤتمر الشعبي العام
اليمني اهلا بك لماذا برايك همم يرد
الامريكيون على اليمنيين عندما يقدمون
البراعيين على تورط ايران بانها غير كافيه
هذه البراهين ما هو السبب
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
له حسابات تخصصه وهي حسابات مصالح ولكن ما
حسابات المصالح مخاتله بمعنى ان انهم
محتفظين بخير يصير لهم بايران ربما
الاستخدامها لاغلاق المنطقه او لبقاء على
ايران واذرعها كفاعها في المنطقه وكان
الاجدر بالامريكيين همم ان يحافظوا على
امن حلفائهم المباشرين في الخليج العربي
همم وفي همم الوطن العربي عوضا عن همم
الرعايه غير المباشره او التعامل الناعم
مع
ايرانها او التغافل عن خطر ايران واذرعها
ان تبقى الحرب في اليمن دائره
في الواقع من الامريكيين ينظرون الى حرب
اليمن الجزء من
تحريك للملفات في المنطقه كلها
وبالتالي هي الحرب في اليمن ترتبط باشياء
كثيره منها
لابقاء على فزاعه لتخويف الخليج العربي
ومنها زعزعه الجزعه الجزئيه لان الخليج
العربي حتى تبقى سوقها من الاسئله
ومنها مدارات
ايران حتى لا تختلط الاوراق او لا تتصادم
مباشره مع امريكا في المنطقه او حفاظا على
امن اسرائيل فهناك تداخلات وملفات متداخله
كثيره في المنطقه تتعلق بهذا الموضوع طيب
الموقف الاوروبي يعني هذه المقابله كانت
قيمه جدا ومهمه من المواقف ايضا اللافته
دور اوروبا تحديدا المانيا تحوي على
الكثير من الحوثيين نعرف ان بريطانيا لها
دور كبير بموضوع الموانئ بموضوع اليمن
بشكل او باخر ولكن دور المانيا مع
الحوثيين ما هو بالضبط
كانت المانيا اولى الدول الاوروبيه التي
تنتظر رفع العقوبات عن ايران وكانت تنتظر
ان تحوز على اكبر رقعه في الكعكه بعد رفع
العقوبات عن ايران وهي لها اهداف
للاستثمار في ايران وتبادل تجاري عالي مع
ايران وبالتالي البدايه ان علاقه ايران
والمانيا كانت علاقه همم جيده مقارنه
ببقيه الدول اوروبا
والايرانيون الحاضرون في المانيا حاضرون
من خلال مراكزهم حاضرون من خلال بعض
المنظمات همم التي تنشط هناك وبعض الخلايا
وبعض وبالتالي افسح هذا المجال
الحوثيه التي وجدت بيئه مواتيه بحكم
الوجود الايراني في المانيا وهمم قبض
الطرف الالماني عن الانشطه الايرانيه
وانشطه حلفائها شكرا لك انا معي دكتور عبد
الحفيظ النهاري رئيس الدائره الاعلاميه في
المؤتمر الشعبي العام اليمني
[موسيقى]
لم تتفاجا واشنطن برفض ايران مقترح احياء
لاتفاقناوي يقول المبعوث الامريكي الخاص
بايران روبرت مالي او هذا القول هو لروبرت
مالي مضيفا ان طهران حطمت كل الامال
المتعلقه باعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي
البيت الابيض هو الاخر اكد للعربيه ان
امريكا ترحب بمحادثات الاتحاد الاوروبي مع
ايران بشان مجموعه واسعه من التحديات لكن
الاتفاق النووي ليس محلات تركيز الولايات
المتحده حاليا في اشاره الى ان الاحتجاجات
في ايران هي الملف الابرز لاهتمامات اداره
[موسيقى]
في شان ايرانيه اخر هوت العمله الايرانيه
الى مستوى منخفض مجددا مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه من جهه وغياب اي مؤشر
بشان تسويه الملف النووي الايراني من جهه
اخرى
الدولار في السوق الايرانيه الحره ارتفع
حديثا مره اخرى حيث تم تداوله عند الساعه
1760 تومان
في تغريده لها على تويتر اعلنت النائب
الفرنسي عن مدينه ساندويني
كليبونتين اوتام عن اعتزامي سلطات
الايرانيه اعدامه ابنها بتمني محمد مهدي
كرمي غدا صباحا وصفه الخطوه بالعار المطلق
هذا ودعت كليوباتين السلطات الفرنسيه
لاتخاد خطوات فوريا لايقاف اعدام معارضين
نظام ايراني باي وسيله متاحه
قبل ذلك دعت رساله لجان دعم المعتقلين
الفرنسيين في ايران الى تحرك منسق من جانب
الدول الاوروبيه اللجان بعثت برساله الى
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل تاكد فيها انه
ينبغي لاقرار ان استراتيجيه باريس في
التفاوض لم تفضي الى اي نتيجه كبيره
وطالبت اللجان من الرئيس الفرنسي اعاده
النظر في استراتيجيه دبلوماسيه وذلك من
اجل وقف معاناه المعتقلين الذين يتعرضون
للابتزاز من قبل السلطات الايرانيه
الرساله ذكرت ايضا ان غالبيه شركاء فرنسا
الاوروبيين لديهم مواطنون محتجون لدى
سلطات الايرانيه
وحتى واقعوا رساله الرئيس مكروه على
اللجوء الى مجلس اوروبا
وذلك عبر استدعاء السفراء ايران لديها
والضغط على ظهره من اجل عوده المواطنين
الى ديارهم شرطا مسبقا لايه علاقه
دبلوماسيه طبيعيه هذا هو تفيد السلطات
الفرنسيه ان تمت سبعه تمت سبعت فرنسيين
معتقلين في ايران بينهم المدرسه والنقابيه
سيسي كولار وزوجها جاك باهي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في السودان اول افاده قضائيه للبشير منذور
اطاحه به ناقدت اعترافاته خلال اجتماعات
سريه كانت بتتها قناه العربيه حصريا
كل المسؤوليه
اما تم في 30 يونيو
واعلم انه الاعتراف هو سيد الادله
تتضارب مع تصريحات سابقه للبشير في
اجتماعات الشورى لما يعرف بالحركه
الاسلاميه تحدث فيها الصراحه عن الدور
الكبير الذي منيح لجماعه الاخوان في
السودان ودورهم في انقلاب 89
الاحوال البشير تحدث بالتسجيلات الحصريه
عن اهميه تسلم جماعه الاخوان للسلطه
بالطريقه التي يقررون
للاخوان بزعامه حسن الترابي وعلي عثمان طه
النائب السابق للرئيس المعزول الذي قاد في
عليا المجموعه المدنيه
انه يشاركني زياده معظم يا اخواننا ان لم
يكن جميعا
انه بالمعطيات التي كانت
89 لو عاد التاريخ القهطره
فازلينقف نفس الموقف وسنن بالتغيير الذي
حدث
اقرار وعلى عثمان طه علانيه يرمز الى ان
جماعه الاخوان كانت الحاكم المتحكمه وان
حزب المؤتمر الوطني يمثل فقط واجهه
للاخوان يتحكمون من خلالها علنا في الدوله
ومواردها
اول واحد الان هي دوله المشروعه الاسلاميه
التي يجب المحافظه عليها وان تكون خيارانا
وجهتنا منصبا للمحافظه عليها للمفارقه
كواليس حصريه للعربيه والحدث تعود لاعوام
تؤكد اليوم النظام المعزول هو ناقد نفسه
باعترافات لا اسس لها تتزامل مع ذكرى
الرابعه للثوره التاسعه عشر من ديسمبر عام
2018 التي اطاحت بالمشي
تتابعون
لمشاركتهم الاحتفال بلقب المونديال ليونيل
ميسي ورفاقه ينضمون الى الجماهير
الارجنتينيه وسط بولس
[موسيقى]
هلا بيكم مجددا في نشره المساء اكد وزير
الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان ان منظمه اوك بلاس تبعد السياسه عن
عمليه صنع القرار والتقييمات واشار الى ان
قرار اوبيك بلاس في اعقابي ازمه اوكرانيا
تبين انه القرار الصحيح لدعم استقرار
السوق والسناعه وحذر من ان مشكله تاسيس
الاحصاءات وتوقعاته حفيظه المستهلكين
وتربكوا السوق واضاف انه لا خيال في
مواجهه قدر كبير من عدم اليقين سوى البقاء
نشطه والسباقيه
[موسيقى]
رحله بحث ياخذها مالك تويتر
جديد
الشركه تتزايد تساؤلات عن شخصيه المدير
الجديد لمنصه تويتر
لمنصب رئيس تنفيذ جديد او سي او في تويتر
هم معاونين ماسك الذين كانوا يساعدونه في
اداره الشركه منذ تواليه منصبهم جيسون
كريشنال
لكن بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه قالت بان
المدير المقبل منصه تويتر قد يكون جاره
كوشنر صهر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب فبعد الاستطلاع الذي اجراه ماسك قام
رجل الاعمال جيسون كلاك كلاكنيس بنشر
استطلاع خاص به يسال المتابعين عما اذا
كان يجب عليه
اداره الشركه بشكل منفصل او معا او ما اذا
كان يجب على شخص اخر توالي المسؤوليه اما
ديفيد سكس فلم يقدم اي موقف خصوصا وانه
يعتبر من بين الفريق المؤسس الاصلي وهو
بايبال يتمتع بخبره في اداره شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي
ووافقه شبكه سينان
كريشنا قد يكون هو الخيار الابراج
للمجموعه خصوصا وانا لديه خبره مباشره في
العمل بتويتر
وعمل سابقا على منتجات اعلانيه في فيسبوك
وسناب شات
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا من واشنطن عباس الباحث الامريكيه
سيد ايهاب اهلا بك فاجئنا صوره سائله
الماسك بعد كوشنر في مباريات نهائي كاس
العالم كانت في تويتر في الدوحه كان رجلان
الى جانبي بعضهم البعض هل لديهم علاقه
صداقه لماذا تشمر من الاسماء المطروحه
لاداره تويتر
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين اا
بالفعل يعني تم التقاط صوره لل الرجلين في
المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم في قطر
وتم ربط هذه الصوره ببعض احداث السابقه
بين رجلين والتقارب في وجهتي النظر بينهما
خاصه وان ماسك في وقت من الاوقات كان
مستشارا خاصا للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ايضا في وقت كان ايضا يمارس مهامه مستشار
شخصي للرئيس دونالد ترامب في ذلك التوقيت
ايران اذا هما يعرفان بعضهم البعض جيدا
ولديهم نفس التوجهات المتعلقه
بحبهم لحزب الجمهوري ولسياسات الرئيس
دونالد ترامب لكن هل عرض ماسك على همم
جاريت كوستر ان يقوم بتولي منصب ال سي او
في تواير او المدير التنفيذي يعني لا توجد
معلومات مؤكده حتى اللحظه في هذا الاطار
لكن توجد
شخصيا يق اما هناك ليشنه همم باختيار سي
او جديد
يعني هذا حتى الان لا توجد اي تفاصيل عنه
لكن هو قال انه سيقوم بالبحث عن همم سي او
جديد او مدير تنفيذ جديد اذا المساله يبدو
انها في يده تماما والفكره اليوم انه حتى
لو خرج الى الماسك من اداره اعتقد انه
سياتي بشخص يخالفه في الاراء ويخالفه في
القرارات وسياتي هل هي بدايه النهايه
لتويتر لهذه المؤسسه المهمه جدا التي
نتواصل كلنا عمرها ام ان اختيار مناسب سي
ياتي بالاستقرار بعد هذه الثوب على
الكبيره على تويتر يعني هل يمكن انقاذ
تويتر
انا اعتقد ان الجزء الثاني من سؤال حضرتك
هو الاقرب والانسب لم نشاهده الان صحيح
تويتر يعيش
موجه عارمه من التقلبات بسبب الاداره
الجديده والقرارات الحاسمه التي اتخذها
الى الماسك خلال الفتره القادمه لكن نؤكد
ايضا ان الى الماسك لم يتخذ هذه القرارات
اعتباطا ان هو رجل جاء وكانت هناك بيانات
مضلله من الممكن ان اا تؤذي الشركه كثيرا
وفكره استحواله على الشركه لذلك لذلك كان
سينسحب من الاستحواذ واول ما قام به عندما
حصل على الاستحواذ قام بفصل الموظفين حتى
كبار الموظفين الذين قدموا لها هذه
المعلومات المدله واريد ان اقول لحضرتك
الى الماسك في نهايه المطاف رجل اعمال لن
يستثمر 44 مليار دولار همم لكي يخسرها في
نهايه المطافئ الى المواصله لديه خطه
استراتيجيه بان يحصل تويتر على مكاسب
ثانويه تقدر ب 26 مليار دولار في واحد
يحصل فيه اليوم على 100 مليارات فقط الباح
في الشؤون الامريكيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تفاجا الجمهور المغربي منتخب بلاده
باستقبال الابطال بسبب ما قدمه من اداء في
مونديال قطر
وعفوا وتحقيق المركز الرابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
موتوسيكل تاكل مغربيه
ناري ناري
[موسيقى]
شو دراري يا سنبول ولد بلادي وهذا
شكوش الع
ريس زي
ز
حكيمي
[موسيقى]
يقدر عليك
[تصفيق]
انضمت حافله المنتخب الارجنتيني الفائز
بكاس العالم الى الاحتفالات في قلب
العاصمه بونسايرس وظهر لاعبون المنتخب
الارجنتيني علمتني حافله مكشوفه قبل ان
تخترق الحشود الهائله من المحتفلين في
بوينسارس
[موسيقى]
ايضا في اخبار الارجنتين حيث حقق الاسطوره
الارجنتينيه ليونيل ميسي رقبا قياسيا
جديدا لكن هذه المره خارج المستطيل الاخضر
فانصروا ميسي ومتابعيه اااه فانصروا ميسي
ومتابعوها على شبكه شبكه التواصل
الاجتماعي جعلوه صاحب المنشور الاكثر
اعجابا في شبكه
انستغرام بحيث تخطط صوره ليونيل ميسي وهو
يحتفل حاملا كاس العالم في ملعب لوسيل
حاجز ال 62 مليون اعجاب ورقم ما زال في
تصاعد ليكسر الرقم القياسي في شبكه
انستغرام والذي بلغ 55.9 مليون اعجاب كما
ان عدد متابعين نجم المنتخب الارجنتيني لي
الماسي على انستجرام ارتفع من 360 مليون
متابع قبل المونديال الى اكثر من 400
وثلاثه مليون في ظرف شهر فقط من بدايه كاس
العالم في قطر نجم حقيقي
[موسيقى]
بعد قطر شمس المونديال لعام 2026 ستشرق من
القاره الامريكيه ضمن نسخه ستكون
استثنائيه بكل المقاييس تعود من خلالها
اجواء المونديال الى بلد العم سام بعد
غياب استمر لاكثر من 28 عاما النسخه
الثالثه والعشرون من كاس العالم ستكون
مختلفه عن سابقاتها بحيث ستنظم على اراضي
ثلاثه بلدان وهي الولايات المتحده وكندا
والمكسيك التي تسجل رقما قياسيا باستضافه
حدث البطوله للمره الثالثه فبعد اربع
سنوات تتوجهوا انذار عشاق الساحره
المستديره الى القاره الامريكيه التي
ستحتضن المشجعين والوفود المشاركه حيث
يرتفع عدد المنتخبات المشاركه الى 48 لاول
مره في تاريخ المونديال
بدلا من 32 فريقا كما هو المعتاد ولاول
مره في تاريخ كاس العالم والتي ستكون
مقسمه على 16 مجموعه وفي كل مجموعه ثلاثه
منتخبات
وستشهد البطوله اقامه 80 مباراه اي بزياده
16 مباراه مقارنه بكاس العالم الذي اقيم
هذا العام في قطر حيث شهد اقامه 64 مباراه
وستجري تلك المباريات في 16 ملعبا بحيث
ستقام المباريات في 11 مدينه امريكيه منها
بوستن واتلانتا وكنسه وهيوسن ولومي فيما
ستستضيف ثلاث مدن مكسيكيه واثنتان كنديتين
المباريات الباقيه
[موسيقى]
في مصر وبعدها عوامل انطلاق العمليه
الشامله سيناء نجحت قوات الجيش والشرطه في
استهداف العديد من العناصر الارهابيه
وترسيخ الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
هكذا تبدو مدينه العريش غياب للكمائن
والمتاريس وتدفق في حركه السيارات والبشر
على وجوه الاهالي بدات ملامح السعاده
والرضا بعد شهور من نجاح القوات الجيش
والشرطه في اقتلاع جذور الارهاب من
المدينه بعد اعوي من محاولات العناصر
الارهابيه لوضع موتى قدم في عاصمه شمالي
سيناء كان الاول في امن كثير وجيش كثير
وغيره وخبطوا دلوقتي ما فيش كله تمام ميه
ميه محافظ شمال سيناء اكد ان الارهاب
اختفى من مدن شمالي سيناء وان نسب الحوادث
ماتت اشبه باي مدينه اخرى مش عايز اكون
مبالغ واقول 100% لان لازم نترك واحد في
المئه او 2% زي اي محافظه في جمهوريه مصر
العربيه بتحصل فيها حوادث عاديه جدا فاحنا
وصلنا لهذا المستوى عودته الاستقرار الى
العريش وانطلاقه وعمليات التنميه انعكسها
على الاهالي ساعات دراسه والعمل صباحا
واوقات السهر ليلا لم تمنع الجميع من
التذكر الدائم لمن قدموا حياتهم ثمنا لهذا
المشهد بالنسبه نحل امنيه الحمد لله
النهارده طبعا فرق بينها وبين السن اللي
فاتت كذلك الطرق كذلك الكمايل النهارده
فتحت الحمد لله والحمد لله كل حاجه متوفره
عندنا في العريش جميله خالص بصراحه وبقت
احلى ولسه هتحلو كمان وكمان
اللي الناس كلها ما كانتش حاسه به لا
دلوقت فرق مليون في المئه من قبل كده
ودلوقتي الناس بتنزل براحتها بتروح
براحتها همم كان الاول لا ما ينفعش مثلا
مخيف شويه دلوقت الناس كلها بتتحرك
بالنسبه المتوقع ان يشهد الشماليه في
الفتره المقبله المزيده من الاخبار
المشاريع التنمويه بعد تقلصي اخبار
العمليات الارهابيه مشهد ياتي بعد عوامل
من التضحيات التي قدمت من الجيش والشرطه
واهالي كمال سيناء من اجل الحفاظ على هذه
الارض احمد عثمان العربيه العريش محافظه
شمال سيناء
عوده للمغرب بمشاهد مباشر همم كان هناك
استقبال حشد للمنتخب المغربي والان توجه
الى القصر الملكي والعاهل المغربي يستقبل
اعضاء الفريق ولا بد انه
يحييهم فردا فردا واللفت والجميل والمؤثر
جدا جدا ان كل لاعب معه والدته همم كما
نشاهد محمد همم
منتخب همم
في انتقائي وتكوين
الان يدخلون برفقتي والدتهم الى قصر
الملكي للقاء العاهل المغربي وطبعا تقديم
التهنئه
من الجميل لحظ جهود المراه والامهات في
تربيه هكذا نجوم
[موسيقى]
يدخلون الان مع امهاتهم الى القصر الملكي
المغربي العاهل المغربيه
يعني اداء التحيه والسلام عليكم
همم ككل الحسود المغربيه والافريقيه
والعربيه
للمفاجاه التي قدمها المنتخب المغربي في
همم هذا المونديال
يتم تقليد
اعتقد ان هو مدرب الفريق
او احد اداري الفريق احد اداري الفريق وكل
لاعب 24 لاعبا دخل برفقه والدته
هذا المدرب هذا مدرب المنتخب المغربي
فعلا مشاهد مؤثره
وليد الرجراجي هو مدرب الفريق المغربي مع
والدته يصافي حامي العاهل المغربي
وطبعا يتم تقليد المدرب في هذه اللحظات
يعني هي نوع من لاحظ جهود هذا الفريق
مع انه يعني لم يصل الى
المركز الاول والثاني ولكن وصل الى مركز
الاول في قلوب العرب
والافارقه وكل من يعني يشجع هذا الفريق
اخبار المساء انتهت والان الى زميله راويه
والعربيات 360 الكلمه لك يعطيك العافيه
اهلا فيك ريما نورت الشاشه شكرا شكرا
جزيلا